how does it feel  I never went to secondary school because  [Music]  katakana is not the wealthiest school in  the district but it's down to each one  of you to decide your own level of  commitment the rains came late this year  and now the trees are gone Malawi is  preparing for a very long Congress's  TNN recorded a single vehicle at sea but  Oh golly mondo ankylosis apana William  Ali Bey Armenian get it and easy  what are you going to do  anything you it's a poem can you fix it  maybe mr. fat you wonder when you turn  the wheel on your bike  the light changes how its magnets I  can't bring water we know how to do it  [Music]  by medical school we stay we die  [Music]  with electricity we can plant in the dry  season and rock off our could see was a  Manasa  [Music]  Malusi italic elite  because it aquatic 30 million attendees  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  somebody to tell about  and delivers accurate  [Music]  you  you